this i was struck by the difference from
week one to week 17.
eagles lost to washington way back in
week one remember it was a 17-point lead
right that was wiped out is that what it
was all the way back in week one was
that what that was
week one when washington was up 17 i
think anyway the post-game
celebration in the locker room what a
difference in
kudos to the teams out there that have
adjusted and adapted i remember being
stunned by the post game with the no
masks and everyone bunched together
after week one week 17 a huge
difference as people take it more
seriously as teams try to avoid
outbreaks
and now as washington moves toward the
postseason trying to keep their guys
healthy and available to play
they'll be hosting the buccaneers on
saturday night on nbc
and kudos to washington for all the
dysfunction
plenty of it self-created but still
they got the right coach to lead them
through it first year on the job
division champs congratulations to ron
rivera and alex smith
rivera fringe coach of the year
candidate alex smith definite comeback
player of the year
winner yeah no definite unbelievable
story i mean the organization's been
through a lot this year
from like every which you know angle
there is i mean holy cow
off the field on the field the name
change everything like that
but they persevered and i think like you
said it is about ron rivera he's just
got a way about him
this calmness always he's the same guy
every day
and when an organization is in turmoil
that's the kind of guy you want you know
leading your
you know leading the command there's a
guy that's the same person and you can
depend on him to
kind of be that day in and day out so
awesome job by him alex smith the whole
football team way to go
good morning to everyone by the way it's
january 4. holidays are over but the nfl
holidays
are looming with the super bowl just a
few weeks away it's pft live we're on
peacock we're on sirius xm 211 oh also
the office is now on peacock and i've
been watching the office all weekend
long they have extended episodes of
season three
if you didn't already have peacock get
it now if you're seeing this you already
have peacock so
what the hell if you're listening on
siriusxm211 make sure you get peacock
if you're watching on nbcsn for the rear
get peacock
and if you're watching on sky sports nfl
sorry i don't think you can get peacock
yet but hopefully one day
you will because why can't they get why
can't they get people i don't think it's
available there yet i feel like it's
available now okay
i didn't know apparently i traveled my
different continents i wasn't sure of
that
it's a new one for me there's
geolocation in your gps in your phone
that keeps that from
happening i guess anyway anyway uh there
is
so much so much to get to today
and and i i tweeted chris that halfway
through the show you're going to be
replaced with nate sudfeld by the way
just so
uh you need to be whoa we're throwing
the show today we're just going to throw
it
the hell with it is that what we're
doing
i don't in this case nate sunfeld
possibly will be an upgrade i don't know
i haven't heard
or seen nate sutfeld talk about football
trying to win the show then yeah okay i
i
i've seen him play football and man what
a way
for this all to come down after the
cowboys and the giants
fight and scratch and claw through an
elimination game
where the losers out and the winner just
has to
go home get some popcorn make some
brisket
have a beer or two settle in and see if
the eagles can knock off washington you
and i both thought
that they would and i think if they had
left jalen hurts in
wire to wire they would have but
it was not to be because
with the game still very much in hand
yep with the eagles still
very much in position to win out went
jalen hurts
and in went knight sud failed and before
we say anything farther we have to
give doug peterson a chance to explain
himself here's the man who supposedly
made the decision
after the game explaining why hertz went
out and sudfield went in
i was coaching and win to win yes that
was my decision
solely um nate has uh obviously been
here for
uh four years um and uh
i felt that uh he he deserved an
opportunity to uh to get some to get
some snaps and um
um listen uh if if there's anything out
there that that thinks that i was
not trying to win the game i mean you
know
ertz is out there brandon graham's out
there darius slays out there you know
all our top guys are still on the field
at the end so
uh we were we were going to win the game
my question to you then is
you know why would you do that is this
just for the draft picks or
is this something else that we're
missing here
pretty simple um i wanted to get the
plan
this week was to get nate sometime and
i felt like it was the time to get him
in the game
that had all of the demeanor and
cadence of something that had been
rehearsed over and over again in his
hotel room mirror
didn't it like he knew this was coming
sure
he'd practiced it i don't buy it
i don't buy it you don't buy it no one
bought it
we don't need to see nate setfield we
know what nate said felt is and of
course they do
is it right they know what nate said
phil i've seen him every day for four
years
and and and look i he here's where i
am upset more than anything else
and we we were texting deep into the
night about
this issue and the ethics of it and i've
been a proponent for years
once you're out of the playoffs what's
the point if you can get
a higher spot in the draft what is the
point
it felt different last night though
because it was a prime time game and
because of all the tentacles that
applied here with washington
winning in and if washington loses the
giants get in
and and it's the last game of the season
and reasonable minds may disagree on
this but
i think the last game of the season has
an extra little oomph to it and
i think if the nfl had any idea this was
going to happen the nfl doesn't pick
that game maybe the nfl goes with no
game in prime time if they have any idea
that the eagles aren't going to be
committed to trying to win it
and and i i'm i'm pissed at myself sorry
london
that i didn't see this coming because
this meshes with the thing that i've
been advocating for the years because it
is
on the surface very smart to go from
nine to six which is what happened for
the philadelphia eagles chris right but
there's something about it that doesn't
sit well with me and it very well could
be
i just didn't see it coming and i'm
upset with myself for not seeing it
coming
and the fact that the eagles did it
makes me upset with my fa
myself that i didn't see it coming and
maybe that's why it bothers me i don't
know maybe this is an
integrity of the game maybe it's just i
wish i would have seen it coming
so i could have been saying all week
long watch out watch out in the second
half
watch out philly's gonna i just didn't
see it i just i felt like in
week 17 the last game of the season with
an opportunity for jalen hurts
to you know put more hay in the barn and
and and
show the eagles that he can get it i
just thought they would go for it
i i mean i i did too i did i can't lie
i mean there's there's a lot of things
to talk about here but i can't fault
them
i mean i think that's the first thing
here yeah i mean it's it's unfortunate
you know mike you've talked about it a
lot like you just alluded to i mean you
really have you've brought it up you've
talked about how much
sense it makes you've talked about the
2014 tampa bay buccaneers right and how
they kind of did it the last game of the
year and all those things you brought up
another example or two
throughout my time knowing you this is
the first time it's happened on the
stage like you're talking about
and on the big stage i mean sunday night
football
you know another team in the nfl their
season is in the balance because of this
and it was just egregiously thrown in
our face
like at what point did you think like
when it was 17-14 and they went for the
touchdown
were you sold at that point they were
like throwing the game or were you just
going uh it's doug peterson he's
aggressive because i will say when it
was
they were down there i think it was
fourth and four right on the goal line
jalen hurts had the
little scramble to the left had a guy
open threw it short
right made a nice play to do all that
but at that point
were you thinking oh are they trying to
throw this or is this jug
doug peterson being you know johnny
analytics so
when did it kind of sink in for you or
when it was when you saw sudfell warming
up
oh yeah it's funny because we do a
digital taping
right after halftime rodney harris and
tony dungy mike tarico and me
and just as we were wrapping that that
fourth down play was happening
and we all kind of like it up analytics
that's that's what tony said
analytics got to go for it on fourth and
four not kick the field goal
what's he thinking oh got to be
aggressive you know all the the stuff
that we've had fun with over time
nobody said oh he's throwing the game by
the time i got back downstairs from my
studio
and shireen williams had texted to all
the pft writers something along the
lines of
is he actually going to put nate sutfeld
in the game what the hell is he thinking
that was when i was like
that's when it started to hit me that
this was happening and
and even though it should have been
obvious
it just was hard to process like you
said it's playing out
on a big stage it's playing out with
stakes involved
for two other teams for the for
washington
and for the giants it had this this
strange confluence of factors
that makes it harder to pull it off
and and that was what someone who's been
involved in the nfl for over 30 years
now pointed out to me last night because
this was creating a ton of buzz yeah and
the idea is
it makes sense but but doing it
hurts your team yeah culturally right it
has
a toll it it it it has a price
and the difference and as we worked this
through last night chris one of the
things that
that kind of stood out for me it's one
thing if you're
tanking to be the worst team in the nfl
and get the first overall pick because a
lot of those guys
that helped you be 1 and 15 2 and 14 0
and 16 they're not going to be there
next year anyway get the hell out who
cares if you're
upset right too bad you should have
played better so we weren't in position
to try to get the first pick
for the eagles it's different a lot of
those guys are going to be back next
year
and they're out there on the last night
of the season you know it's got you know
as
we've and it first kind of dawned on me
with the texans lions and thanksgiving
there's a bowl game quality to it where
your
your people are watching you play and
we're out here we're playing hard and we
got a chance to screw things up for
washington and
wait a minute we're not trying we're
just we're just pulling the plug now
yeah it's gonna be a lot of damage it
needs to be undone and i don't think the
eagles thought all that through
before they decided to implement this
plan which i don't think came from doug
peterson i think it came from hiring the
organization yeah i would imagine so too
i would think this is a total
organizational decision
owner gm everybody involved to go this
route
and i mean i was just gonna go that
direction too before you said it
because that's the other reason we don't
see it you know you kind of explained it
right
yeah maybe it's those teams that are oh
and whatever or one and whatever but
it's rare where you see a team like this
who was
still in the playoff race last week
who's had many
uh a press conferences this year that
you know oh we're doing everything we
can to win and do all those things
and then as doug peterson mentioned
all those guys were out there playing
putting their
butts on the line and one of the more
dangerous sports in the whole world
and the organization wasn't really
trying to win and that's where
guys will go home and go that's bs and
they'll have a beer with each other
later today and go that's bs
and then they're going to talk about
that in the offseason and go man i don't
know do i trust coach did he lie to us
those things are going to be part of it
that's why teams don't do that
that's why i don't think a lot of the
big time coaches would
fold tents like that and those kind of
things because they don't want to set
that culture and get it going so i do
think that's a very
delicate balance there and they
obviously thought the three picks were
worth
and doug peterson's people skills could
overcome it and i don't doubt that
because doug peterson
he does have amazing people skills and
that team loves him
it reminds me in a weird sort of way of
all the damage that pete carroll had to
undo
after the decision to throw and not run
at the goal line in super bowl 49
right stuck with guys it didn't go away
and ultimately i think they had to just
part ways with
multiple players before they were going
to wash that out of the organization
that may be what the eagles have
acquired here and when you consider
on paper the value and and this isn't
apples to apples
but three spots in the top ten what's
that worth
to go from nine to six when the jets
moved from six to three in 2018 to get
in position to get sam darnold
they gave up two second round picks in
2018 and a second round pick in 2019
so it was worth three second round picks
high
value players that can form a
significant part of the nucleus of your
team
given up by the jets to just go from six
to three so and and this is an example
of you know we hear about analytics all
the time within the confines
of decisions made during a game but the
concept
is broader than that the concept is
turning the sport of football
into something that is analyzed with
numbers and probabilities and statistics
in mathematics and
from an analytical standpoint this was a
no-brainer
there's nothing to be gained by the
philadelphia eagles by winning that game
last night nothing to be gained
who cares about the difference between 4
11 and 1
5 10 and 1. who cares right it does not
matter at all to anyone you're not
making the playoffs
it's over it's done that extra loss
means jack diddley
squat but
losing yeah it's it's it's it's got it's
it's got it's
it's worth its weight in gold you you
move from nine to six
people give up multiple second round
draft picks to make that kind of a move
at the top tenth so
fine makes sense but but
you lose a piece of your soul as a
football team and it's not going to be
easy to get it back
yeah i think that's the that that's you
know the balance and and
i understand them doing it you know it's
a delicate one
certainly they have confidence i think
that a doug peterson
can can find the right balance and tone
with his football
players and the the main leaders in that
locker room
and you know you just don't know you
know again
like like you said it's worth its weight
in gold
i mean a number three spots up number
six you're doing all you can do
that's a great asset how do you know
we don't know yet but you know we could
get to draft time
and what if it was the other way around
they won the game right
and okay like you're saying oh
whoop-dee-doo they're 5 10 and one now
they're the number nine seed
and what if they need let's just talk
hell well there's two unbelievable pass
rushers in the draft this year
they're gonna be gone by pick number
seven then you're gonna go what was that
win at the end of the year
worth it when we have a guy here that we
think could could have changed our team
next year
so that's what they're banking on that
that they're going to have a
position or at least teams who are
willing to want to trade up to that
position
and it's going to improve their team
that way so i think there's a lot into
that
i i'm with you mike here's the other
part of it and let me just ask you this
because this has occurred to me as you
know watching the game there last night
i mean do they do this last night
we know to lose the football game but
is it also a double whammy of
let's maybe trill still try to save the
carson wentz thing
and not let jalen hurts win the game and
have to hear that and go into the off
season with that
are doug peterson and howie roseman
still trying to salvage that situation
that's just one angle that popped up to
my head too that they didn't want to win
that game and have to deal with that
conversation because they still
carson wentz is their guy i don't know
what's your thought on that
i agree with you completely completely
especially because of what we talked
about during the pregame show and what
i've reported yesterday at pft and
talked about it last night
they want to get past this season
they're going to press pause they're
going to get some distance and then
they're going to sit down and make a
decision
about what the quarterback position will
be in 2021
will once be reinstalled as the starter
will there be an open competition
between wentz and jalen hurts or will
jalen hurts keep the job that's decision
number one
yeah but they still believe in carson
wentz and if you go back and look at
some
other franchise quarterbacks early in
their careers ben roethlisberger third
year of his career
he had a regression it didn't last
peyton manning
peyton manning the jim moore playoffs
year they were six
and ten yeah peyton manning was like 26
touchdown passes 23 interceptions
he regressed in year four of his career
right and they fixed him
and so there's a belief that they're
going to fix him they've given up
too much they've made too much of an
investment to just throw him out in the
trash
so you're right chris if jalen hurts
pulls off this big win in prime time and
knocks washington out of the playoffs
and everybody says oh jalen hurts is the
guy and you create this
expectation in philadelphia exactly he's
the starter for 2021
right he makes it harder to implement a
rational
plan based on what we think the future
will be
and and and so i i think there is
something to that
that it's we didn't want the jalen hurts
monster
to be too too big yeah we didn't want
this to be a thing
that made it an inevitability that he's
the starter next year and if they win
that game with a last
second run to the end zone by hertz and
everybody celebrates and
and they knock out washington uh yeah
there's a chance that
you can't put that genie back in the
bottle no you're right they're backed
into a corner and
in in every and every which way if that
happens
you know let alone you lose the three
spots in the draft so i mean that to me
i think in totality is really what was
done here
yeah three spots in the draft there's a
lot of value sorry it was on sunday
night football
and you know they teased the country
there for a little while to think oh my
gosh and especially me
and my little son phillip sims i mean
yeah his name's phil sims you know we
were rooting for the damn eagles we
wanted the giants to get in the damn
playoffs
so we were pissed sitting there but
regardless they did what they thought
was best for their organization
and they more than any other team i
think
in the league are headed towards the
most interesting offseason in all of
football
so they had to approach it delicately i
mean it's really interesting
we're you know you laid it out there
it's a guy they traded for he's the
number two pick of the draft he's played
at an mvp level
he's carried the team in 2019. this year
he fell apart and looked like crap
they drafted a guy who's got some
following he's got a great
charisma and leadership to him he played
well
and if jalen hurts wins they can't get
rid of either guy or
they're not going to win they're in a
no-win situation they try to get rid of
jalen hurts people are going to go how
could you do that he should be the guy
right and if jalen hurts wins carson
wentz's
uh their leverage to ask for a trade or
anything like that is going to go way
way down too because people are just
going to go well the philadelphia
they want jalen hurts and they got to
get rid of carson wentz this isn't going
to work
so i think from all those you know
things it makes sense
and i think ideally they'd like to find
a way to keep both on the roster because
of all teams in the nfl the eagles
understand the value of having two
capable quarterbacks
that's how they won the super bowl
that's how they almost got back to the
final four in 2018
when carson wentz can't play you need
someone else who can come in and play
and obviously that someone else is not
yeah nate sutfeld
they wanted to be jalen hurt what'd you
say mike last night that they value the
backup quarterback
is what a um a top 15 position on the
roster
that's yeah that says a lot i mean it's
smart team building i understand that
certainly like you said it did it won
them a super bowl
all right there was a gif making the
rounds of jalen hurts on the sidelines
saying it's not right it's not right
that's not what he said after the game
uh because he's because he's not going
to bear his soul
in front of a microphone but let's hear
from jalen hurts on getting benched
following the loss to washington
every as a competitor um i i play to win
um and you know you got to trust uh
just coach with that you know nate's
worked really hard
um all year you know and
i think he's a great player you know
coach wanted to give him opportunity at
some point in the game
um and you know he was given the
opportunity obviously
like i said me being a competitor um
talk about winning all the time going
out there and trying to win all the time
and that's what i'm all about but like i
said i trust coach with that that's
all i can do about that jerseys guys i
got an
old school eagles jersey it looked like
this that wasn't that wasn't the game
jersey from last night i'd love to have
seen what he was wearing under there
michael it looked like an old i thought
it said seven one time maybe it was a
michael vick jersey
yeah possibly yeah yeah
but uh yeah look he's not he's not gonna
he's not gonna call it out but it's
gonna stick with him too he's gonna be
one of the guys
moving forward that doug peters is gonna
have to spend time talking to
to explain what he did and you know at
some point does peterson just
lay it on the line with these guys and
say look we we just wanted to get the
higher draft pick
well that's that's what we wanted to do
we're going to be better off we're going
to be a better team next year
sitting at number six instead of number
nine in round one two three four five
six
seven i i i think so at some point i
think he's probably gonna
he might that might happen today in the
exit meeting maybe tomorrow whatever
where he pulls aside
a few of the leaders on this football
team to kind of let them know
so word trickles out throughout the
roster to go like okay coach kept it
real with us and
now we know what was going on but jalen
hurt said something interesting there
too you know to the point of what we're
talking about
and how there is a balance there because
he said we talk about winning
all the time you know that's what we're
all about he said that
that's what we talk about that's what
we're all about
so that just shows you see the players
are going to go back home and have
a beer or sit there tonight and go wait
what the hell what the hell was that so
i do think it would be important for
doug p peterson to get out
and talk to guys and kind of let them
know what what the overall
over organizational you know oversight
was here
and i think yeah do it fast yeah you do
the exit interviews with the players
right on the heels of this season ending
and and i think that
that message needs to be addressed
or he will have already lost his locker
room
for 2021. i i don't know that yeah yeah
yeah look at that sounds extreme
but if you don't handle this the right
way you you create a cloud that's going
to hang over
your team next year and it's going to be
hard to undo
the damage and you're going to get the
side eye from time to time
from certain key players when you make
certain decisions there's going to be
snarky comments from time to time when
when decisions are made by the coach and
again this may not have even been a
decision
that was made by the coach yeah the one
thing the one thing
that should have been obvious the moment
this happens once
once once we set aside our desire to be
entertained
and watch a good game that was maybe
going to go down to the wire
just like last year between the 49ers
and the seahawks to finish the regular
season
once you set that aside one of the
epiphanies that you have is
peterson's definitely safe there's no
question about it he's not going to be
part of his plan
if he's not going to be part of the team
next year he he's
implementing what someone else has
decided was in the best interest of the
team
and uh him going along with it shows
that he's not going to be getting a pink
slip
this week no no no absolutely not you're
right this is you know
hey let you know he could always say
yeah we were doing whatever we had to do
to win right that's what he said when he
put nate sutherland in 2021
i mean that's what they're doing you
know that's right that's right
i'm planning to win next year after
right exactly right it's it's
you know he just left that part out of
it he didn't finish the center good so i
like that that's what that's what he did
there
and you know we'll see what they do the
philadelphia eagles but it is going to
be interesting and i'll say this to last
the last thing mike because like
i know yeah it's so disappointing that
we
had that game last night and i'll just
throw out to the nfl
one more time i don't think we would
have had this problem if we had the
battle for the number two seed
by week we would have had a game that
had real importance somewhere
and this was the only one that had any
true guaranteed importance and i don't
know
i mean what can the league do to stop
this call the eagles on sunday and go
hey if we put you on sunday night are
you guys in a tank
or are you going to play i mean you know
so that's where it's tough
see and and part of the reason that that
call doesn't happen
is because the nfl's attitude toward
tanking has been to just
ignore it i've used the example in the
past a good friend of mine he had four
brothers they had a little dog the rule
was if the dog pooped on the rug
whoever noticed it had to clean it up so
what happened no one ever noticed it it
just sat there forever
that's what the nfl's attitude toward
tanking is it's that poop on the rug
that it refuses sorry i'm sorry i enjoy
your breakfast
that the nfl refuses to notice that it
refuses to acknowledge
doesn't want to have a draft lottery
because you have to acknowledge that
there's an incentive there's there's
this firewall crisp between
win win win win win win and oh hey look
at this they've got the first overall
pick in the draft
and it's like they don't want fans to
understand the connection between losing
and enhancing your draft status and
people have figured that out yeah
that that ship has sailed and so yes i
think that's now i think is
the nfl learns year after year how best
to program that last game of the season
this is now a factor
that needs to be considered going
forward because
another game may have been better or or
no game right like we saw a few years
ago
maybe you just play them all in that six
hour window
sometimes that's the best decision to
make because there isn't a game that's
going to have that compelling finish
like we saw last year between
the seahawks and the 49ers um
let's not completely ignore washington
though in this segment
we have some sound from both ron rivera
and alex smith
from the uh aftermath of an unlikely
division title here they are
i all i care about it says division
champs uh
it's still alive um you know and that
that was
every off season when you get together
as a team the number one goal the the
easiest way to
get a ticket to the dance is win the
division and uh
you know it it certainly wasn't looking
likely there for a long time the
beginning of the year for us and and uh
to be here now though like i said i
think says a lot about the character we
got don't judge us from where we've been
judge us for where we're going so let's
see how we handle this
going forward you know this is a big
opportunity for us
um you know i love what they said about
just getting in
and and that's all we needed was a
chance to get in we'll see what happens
we're going to play against a very good
football team with uh you know
uh a lot of good football players and so
i'm excited about it
last time a team with a losing record
got into the playoffs it was ron
rivera's panthers in 2014
seven eight and one and they won
in the wild card round now they faced
ryan lindley
not tom brady big difference a little
because carson palmer was hurt for the
cardinals but then after
winning that game the panthers went to
seattle and gave the seahawks who were
the defending super bowl champions at
the time a run for their money
i'm not ready to just completely
scratch washington off the tree but
i'm close i mean the pencil is there
yeah
it's ready to start it's ready to start
going back and forth and back and forth
with washington
gone chris uh but you know we'll see
crazier things have happened
well there's some redeeming things about
their football team that you like
definitely um but you know i think
ultimately
it's gonna be about their defense their
defense does i mean it matches up well
with anybody we know that
and anytime we've seen hey oh brady
issues
it's a front four that can drop seven
into coverage do those type of things
but washington football team is
offensively challenged as you saw last
night and antonio gibson's not 100 and
terry mclaurin's not 100
they need them to get you know closer to
being
totally back to 100 for them to have a
chance but i think ultimately too it's
gonna be a game where if washington's
defense doesn't
create a turnover or two or something
like that
yes i think they're outmatched in this
one this is you know like you said this
is not ryan lindley this is brady and
a whole bunch of other awesome players
coming to town
still we will be very exciting to see
what the buccaneers can do
in the postseason they have gotten
better and better and better as the
seasons unfolded and yeah this is not
a game that that washington should be
looking forward to but
the mindset is we got nothing to lose
everybody expects
us to lose let's just go play football
and we'll see what happens and it's not
like anyone is going to be highly
critical of washington
for blowing a game against the
buccaneers where they are going to be
significant underdogs as they should be
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports